hahaha what what sup guys Greg here I am
going to do a music video reaction John
is not in today
I saw that joint of Lucas I saw the
thumbnail for this I was like oh it's
paying homage to Will Smith's MIB
and come to find out it's called will
and I hear this sums about Will Smith
who pays a lot of Amash to him and I
heard about Will Smith loving this song
I haven't actually heard any details on
it but I was like I just gotta check
this out I want to watch it I love join
her Lucas fantastic rapper Will Smith
legendary I am Legend you guys see that
rap that he did that was on his vlog
directors make movies I make director
such good line I might not look like a
white boy but when I start dancing or
nodding my head to stuff I look like a
dumb ass wipe
[Music]
fresh fruits
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go into I imagine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's beautiful that's beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
oh is that defect you don't try to build
a wall you say I'm gonna lay this brick
and soon you have a long wall
awesome I love that that was freaking
awesome I directed it too huh
good for him kid has potential man
there's so much I loved about that like
yeah the beat is great and the lyrics I
thought were really impressive too he
managed to weave in all the titles all
these references right down to Mike
Lowrey in the lyrics without making it
feel cheesy or you know corny or
ham-fisted many years ago I did a a poem
that suddenly turned into a rap as I was
recording it called dear Ryan it's a
tribute to Ryan Gosling thinking about
all the nights I look up to the sky
praying to God this is Ryan right if you
really thought from the above could I
call this Crazy Stupid Love
hey similar thing where I was like
referencing all the the titles and stuff
more for jokey purposes obviously when
he was doing it he managed to pull it
off in a way that just sounded really
badass weaving all the difference I'm
from Fresh Prince beating all the tiles
all the way right down to Genie and
Aladdin in it and I thought that was
really great but beyond that it's like
you get a sense just in the last few
lyrics why he's doing this song
obviously paraphrasing here but talking
about a lot of us have like our heroes
that we really look up to we don't get a
chance to maybe show them their
appreciation we don't get a chance to
say bye to them and a lot of times you
are tributes to the heroes of or now
gone
you know post-death I think it's really
great that he he put this whole tribute
together compose this song while the
guys still alive that final line about
like give him a rose while they're still
alive show me that you don't have to
wait till they're dead or something in
order to actually pay homage to them
like this is full on the whole the whole
song is about him and then doing the
music video as well the way the
transitions were all done constantly
segwaying into different visuals that
represent stuff like Fresh Prince men
and black you know all the movies and
right down to Wawa West which is one of
the best karaoke songs ever
by the way Jordan Lucas is a widely
successful rapper right now and I first
discovered him from listening to collab
tracks that he did with Eminem and using
this platform and his music to pay
homage to the man who inspired him for a
Will Smith like I decided to check this
out because I saw Will Smith it's not a
title about it how he's reacting to it I
could just imagine just how beautiful
that is because it's kind of like this
ripple effect you have Will Smith who
did his thing became a successful rapper
huge television star than a huge movie
star and then even the image that he has
outside of there like slapping on you
don't try to build a wall a quote from
an interview that I think that interview
was with Charlie Rose I remember years
ago watch the used to watch it
repetitively the philosophy of Will
Smith there was like a ten minute
compilation that someone put together
you can find out a lot more from Will
Smith out on YouTube he's a very deep
thought-provoking speaker and he's
heavily into personal development and
there's a lot about work ethic there's
great audio I either other channel
motivation madness or motive ersity that
I found where it's like a 20 minute
discussion or a 10 minute discussion
talking about his interpretation of what
self discipline means and how self love
is self discipline that's something
that's always really stuck with me the
line at the end about to build a wall
and you lay this brick one brick at a
time that concept of like inch by inch
is a since yard by yard is hard and
looking into the details one step at a
time instead of just only focusing on
the end result and really paying
attention to the steps the journey like
Will Smith it is I think an inspiration
overall so you have him and then now you
got Joyner Lucas oh I'm sure has a lot
more people that he considers like the
the men he looked up to the idols or
whatever but giving this this glorious
homage to Will Smith and I'm sure there
are plenty of people now the way how he
viewed Will Smith now there are people
who are viewing Joyner Lucas that same
way and I've got open to start some
weird tread new people there of rappers
doing like a lot of Omar's songs to
people as an artist that they that they
have greatly inspired them like while
these artists are still alive I think
that'd be a really cool thing to do yeah
I was really impressed with this this
was freaking beautiful and like the way
he drew the parallels of his
is life I think that's why the lyrics
work so well
with dropping the names of characters or
primarily the the movie titles work so
well because he wasn't just like rapping
about the movies or the shows anytime he
used one of the titles he would use it
in correlation to his life so while
you're watching the journey of Will
Smith's career
you're also honing in on the journey and
the things that inspired Joyner Lucas
paralleling that journey as well as
paralleling a work and write down to
what he's seen from will psmith personal
life of how his personal life has in
turn inspired how he wants to run his
own personal life as well this is great
this is fantastic
yeah well I got to do this thanks for
being here guys John usually doesn't
music video reactions at our patreon
page for do weekly Q&A see be sure
reaction watch along several other shows
every action highlights included and he
does music video reactions weekly
sometimes I join him join or him what do
you think of this video
who's your favorite rapper of all time
which celebrity do you think is your
biggest inspiration that you would love
to pay homage to in some way leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click the
notification bell
catch ya soon didn't even fully wake but
I made the noise as if I was winking
I was feeling blue with their tubas my
Valentine and thinking about you and how
you just redefine all acting when you
did the place beyond the pines when I
asked you what you do I want you to say
I Drive drive my